SETH VARGO: Hi there.
And welcome to the third
video in our series
on SRE and DevOps.
My name is Seth, and
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And
I'm Liz, an SRE focused
on teaching Google Cloud
customers how to build
and operate reliable services.
SETH VARGO: In the
previous video,
we discussed the differences
between SLIs, SLOs, and SLAs.
SLIs are quantitative
measurements, like latency.
SLOs are the amount
of time that an SLI
can be out of specification.
And SLAs are business agreements
with explicit consequences
for failing to deliver service.
But what stops teams from
breaking their agreed upon SLOs
and forcing SREs
to work overtime?
It seems like a classic
DevOps problem where
product teams want
to ship new features,
but SREs need to
maintain a reliability.
Is there anything
in the SRE program
that can help with
this classic problem?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That's what
we use error budgets for.
SETH VARGO: Error budgets?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Well, before
we talk about error budgets,
let's talk about risk
and availability.
As I mentioned in the previous
episode, trying to go for 100%
availability just isn't a good
idea because it's expensive.
It's technically complex.
And in a lot of cases, it
winds up being the case
that users don't even see
the benefits of it because
of end reliability somewhere
else in this system.
SETH VARGO: I see.
That makes a lot of sense.
Because if my cellular
network is only 99% reliable,
but my service is
99.9% reliable,
my users are never going to
experience that additional 0.9%
of reliability because
they're cellular network
is likely to fail
before my service does.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
That's exactly correct.
So while we want to reduce
the risk of system failures,
we have to accept
some degree of risk
in order to deliver these
products and features.
SETH VARGO: But
how do we determine
how much risk a service
is willing to tolerate?
LIZ FONG-JONES: So that's
a product decision.
So we have to work with the
product's management team
to figure out what
is our explicit goal
for the availability
target of our service.
And there are many
things to think about,
like how much is it going
to cost to add extra fault
tolerance, or to add
extra testing time,
or to reduce our
frequency of pushes,
or to increase how long
it takes for us to decide
that a release is good compared
to the benefits to the user
of increased reliability.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So the acceptable risk of
a system dictates the SLO,
and the SLO mathematically
defines the error budget.
If the service incurs
too much downtime,
we have to reduce the risk to
remain within the SLO, which
might mean halting deployments.
If service owners
want to deliver
a lot of risky
features, they have
to be willing to accept
a much looser SLO.
Because if they were
to choose a strict SLO,
they would quickly exceed
their error budget, which
could halt future deployments.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
So the main benefit
of an error budget
is that it's a quantitative
measurement that's
shared between the product
and SRE teams, which
means that we can balance
innovation and stability
to an appropriate level.
SETH VARGO: So as long
as the SLOs are met,
releases can continue.
But how do we know if an SLO
breach is about to occur?
LIZ FONG-JONES: So when we
defined earlier the expectation
of how much uptime a
service is going to have
and how we're going
to measure it,
well, we need to actually
concretely implement
that using a
neutral third party,
like a monitoring system.
SETH VARGO: Well,
and the metrics
on that monitoring system,
those are the SLIs, right?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
And the difference
between the actual uptime
and the calculated target
uptime from our SLO
is the budget of how
much unavailability
that we can tolerate
for the system
to be stable over the
entire window of the SLO.
So we call this
the error budget.
If your SLIs are
failing all the time,
then you're going to be burning
through your error budget.
And then eventually, you need
to stop your feature releases
in order to focus instead on
making reliability improvements
and restructuring your
application so that it can
meet your SLOs in the future.
SETH VARGO: So who enforces
those policies, though?
Because couldn't a product team
just go over and break the SLO
and force the SREs
to work overtime?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
So this is why we
need to have executive
buy-in for error budgets.
If the SRE teams
don't have the ability
to enforce the error budgets,
then the whole system
is going to break down.
So some teams just allow
for a limited number
of tokens or golden bullets
that you can hand out to a vice
president, for example.
So if a product
team really wants
to get that critical
feature out,
well, they're going to
have to ask their vice
president for a
one-time exception,
and they'll only get a
certain number per year.
SETH VARGO: I see.
But what about things that are
outside of the product team
that aren't necessarily
buggy code for my developers,
like someone cuts
an undersea cable,
or there's a catastrophic
failure at a data center?
Those shouldn't impact
my error budget.
It wasn't my fault.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
this is why it's
important to have error
budgets from top to bottom
for everything in your stack.
That way you can figure out how
much error budget you allocate
to your dependencies and how
much error budget is reserved
for your developers to spend.
And this is another reason why
targeting 100% availability
isn't realistic, because
all of your dependencies
are not 100% available either.
SETH VARGO: That
makes a lot of sense.
But what about other things
like restarting a failed service
or other kind of manual tasks?
Are those considered
part of the error budget?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah.
So Seth, when you have
to do manual action
to keep your system from
failing, in the wait
before you actually
do that manual action,
you'll start burning
through your error budget.
But the actual act of
doing that manual work,
we track that separately.
And that's a concept
that we call toil.
So we'll talk about that more
in detail in the next video.
SETH VARGO: Great.
So risk and error budgets
are directly related
to many of the DevOps
principles that we've
discussed in earlier episodes.
It clearly defines
that accidents
are normal by
quantifying accidents
and risk through error budgets.
It also enforces that
change should be gradual
because a non-gradual
change could quickly
burn through the error budget
for a particular product
breaking the SLO and
preventing further deployment
for the quarter or for the year.
This has really helped a lot.
I think it's really clear why
we say that class SRE implements
DevOps.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Thanks,
everyone, for watching.
Check the description below
for links and more information.
Don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
and stay tuned
for our next video
where we talk
about toil budgets.